hey guys tim ferriss here i am asked a
lot about tea and coffee and red wine
but i don't talk about other types of
booze very often and the fact of the
matter is there's some real gem so I'm
going to share a few that I uses my
go-to s so this right here is called
heat OD Musa man Dody muslimah is single
daughter study Musume sake and this is a
Zygon jewel and the way i came about
this particular stock is I went to a
sock a store and at the same time
coincidentally there was a book signing
by a gent who had written a guide to
sake and I spoke to him about Japan I
spoke to him in Japanese for a period of
time and went through my likes and
dislikes and this was a sucka he
recommended and it is incredible at
least to my palate to my personality
that's my dog chewing on a yak milk one
in the background if you're wondering
it's not someone having their fingers
snapped off this stuff is incredible so
this is my go-to sake and having lived
in Japan for a while that says quite a
bit I think all right next is a white
wine and I very rarely drink white wine
is not a white wine I never have been
there are two particular white wines
where I have been sitting at a table of
red wine drinkers and they've all been
taken aback by how delicious the white
wine is number one was that Brix a
restaurant up in Napa County here in
Northern California is a wine country
and it was the 2007 Rombauer Chardonnay
incredible incredible white wine in fact
at the time that was the first case of
wine I ever bought and I was a red wine
person that was white wine this is
another so this is butternut 2013
chardonnay from California and I had
this at a tech icons house here in
Silicon Valley and he had this stocked
basically to the ceilings just 900
bottles this stuff and he would give it
to guests when they visited it as one of
the options this stuff is great it is
not that expensive nor is the he Tony
Muslim it so I thought I'd give you at
least one option that is
ridiculously expensive and that is this
one right here now by ridiculously
expensive I don't mean thousands of
dollars but as far as tequila goes
expensive this is Casa Dragones
sipping tequila and I was introduced to
this you can see my name is on the
bottle very fancy this cost I want to
say about two hundred and seventy five
dollars you can get it for less there is
another version that I think cost about
seventy-five I would say equally
delicious so they're both fantastic
this particular tequila was introduced
to me by a former Navy SEAL and I was
training with him in Idaho doing some
firearms training and afterwards when he
would clean all of the weapons along
with a handful of other military and
former military they would very slowly
sip this tequila while cleaning the
firearms now no loaded weapons of course
very safely done but just kind of
sitting around relaxing afterwards with
costs that are going to sipping tequila
I want to underscore what that means
that means no cocktails you're not
mixing this with some crappy like
cranberry juice and swinging it down or
taking shots no no no I put these in
little sake glasses and it's just a
little set little sip then you put it
down then a little sip so be civilized
people be civilized I never like to kill
it always burn my throat gave me a
horrible hangover no hangover with this
in my experience no terrible burning
feeling nothing it's a totally different
experience so Casa della goin is those
are the three you have heat 30 Musume
sake you have butternut Chardonnay and
then you have costigan is tequila enjoy
have you heard of five bullet Friday
well if you haven't that's good news I'm
excited because it is my most exclusive
content it is free and you can check it
out right here
lots of actionable tactics tools and
more